حسنًا ، هذه النقطة الزمنية من غير الواضح سبب قيام
روسيا بالضبط على ما يبدو بحرق الكثير
من الغاز في منشأة بورتوفايا التي
تقع بالطبع على الحدود مع
فنلندا ، وتقول شركة الأبحاث ريستاد
إنها تعتقد أنه يمكن أن يكون هناك
عدة أسباب لذلك.
أوجه القصور في حركة الغاز الطبيعي المسال في روسيا ،
يمكن أن يكون الروس أيضًا
يختبرون تلك المنشأة بعد الصيانة
التي تم إجراؤها ، لكنهم يقولون
أيضًا إنه قد تكون هناك أسباب سياسية أيضًا
، وإذا نظرنا إلى موقع
محطة الغاز الطبيعي المسال هذه ، فمن المؤكد أنها تبدو
وكأنها في  موقع مهم للغاية
في الواقع ، إنه يغذي مباشرة
خط أنابيب نوردستريم واحد الآن
كان هناك الكثير من المشاكل مع خط الأنابيب هذا
مؤخرًا ينتهي خط الأنابيب في ألمانيا
ويقول الألمان في الوقت الحالي
إنه يحمل فقط حوالي 20 في المائة
من السعة التي يمكن لخط الأنابيب أن يستوعبها.
حمل الروس يقولون إن ذلك بسبب
أعمال الصيانة على التوربينات
المطلوبة لتدفق الغاز العالي ، فإن الألمان
لا يصدقون ذلك  يقولون إنهم يعتقدون
أن الأمر سياسي خاصة في
ضوء حقيقة أن لديهم توربينًا جاهزًا
يجلس في ألمانيا ويقولون إن روسيا
في هذه المرحلة لن تقبل أن
يقول الروس إن ذلك بسبب
العقوبات الدولية التي تجعل الأعمال الورقية
صعبة لذا فهي صعبة للغاية.  من الصعب
تحديد سبب حرق الروس لهذا الكم الهائل
من الغاز ، لكن لا شك في أن هذا هو
الغاز الذي تحتاجه الكثير من الدول في
أوروبا الآن بشدة لأن أسعار الغاز على
المستوى الدولي بالتأكيد
في ارتفاع. fred platkin cnn Moscow